as putin makes moves our leaders are
struggling for answers joe biden spoke
to the american people today and seemed
detached
russia's moved troops closer to
ukraine's border with russia
russia's naval vessels are maneuvering
in the black sea to ukraine south
including amphibious assault ships
missile cruisers and submarines
russia's move supplies of blood and
medical equipment into position on their
border
you don't need blood unless you plan on
starting a war
this does feel like a war's begun it
didn't take long for americans to feel
it in their bank accounts the global
economy shuttered
and oil is close to a hundred bucks a
barrel
and gas prices
up nearly a dollar a gallon since last
year and after this heading to four
bucks a gallon
but the very first time biden admitted
oh this might affect you
was today
and it's just the beginning
defending freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that we're
closely monitoring energy supplies
for any disruption this will blunt gas
prices i want to limit the pain to the
american people our feeling at the gas
pump
biden says he has a plan i hope it's
better than his plan to crush the virus
right now looks like putin gets ukraine
and we get higher gas prices
we at jesse waters prime time wanted to
know what the american people thought
about this jump at the pump so today we
hit the streets
[Music]
what do you think about these high gas
prices
uh
i think they're ridiculous they're
ridiculous insane too expensive it's a
lot it's difficult for us it's horrible
it's 529 here i can't afford that
how much does it cost you to fill up
your tank
my tank 80 bucks over a hundred
territory cost me about a hundred
dollars
other places costing about fifty sixty
dollars hundred and ten dollars
regular russia just invaded ukraine and
the gas prices are going to go up big
time
what should joe biden do
resign you should think about the people
living in america that's it we
definitely have to quail this because
if this keeps happening we're gonna have
to park our cars he's gonna do these
sanctions on supposedly right
and russia
but that's not gonna help us any because
the prices are gonna go up so gas prices
are already up a dollar under joe biden
way more than a dollar it is double it's
definitely double what has he been doing
wrong
uh everything maybe he could wake up
we have a whole list he's focused too
much on
big ideas and his legacy
and less on what's hurting the
individual consumer every day and i
think he needs to really focus on what's
going on over here as far as inflation
prices everything is going up i don't
think biden is really focusing on
on the real issues of america's of what
americans need
how much more can you take
i can't take it yet now you know so
that means you know i can't take laps
that's more you know so i'm ready to the
neck you know if that happens i'm taking
the bus of the train
not much more and i guess uh the rich
don't have to worry about these things
any message to joe biden about the high
gas prices focus on america and forget
about everything else take care of all
america and all americans don't let the
gas prices go up get them lower we don't
belong in russia ukraine anything and
you could definitely leave office that
would be great
so the people don't care about russia
the ukraine the way the europeans do we
care about our money our borders and our
safety
we just want biden to do something for
us for once not his donors not the
allies and his family members just once
for us
he's begging the saudis to throw him a
bone and pump some more oil but they're
standing by their new friends russia and
giving us the middle finger
so joe's running out of friends and
options
he spent years telling us he was putin's
worst enemy
the fact is that i've gone head-to-head
with putin and made it clear to him
we're not going to take any of his stuff
putin knows if i am president united
states his days of tyranny and trying to
intimidate the united states and those
in eastern europe are over
i'm going to stand up to him he's a
bully
that's just tough talk that's all that
was the minute joe got into office he
dropped sanctions on russia's pipeline
to germany and he killed our pipeline
from canada
i have been opposed to nordstrom 2 from
the beginning
but it only has a it's almost completed
by the time i took office and uh to go
ahead and
close sanctions now
but i think is counterproductive in
terms of our european relations
they know how strongly i feel
and uh
i hope we can uh
work on how they handle it from this
point on
biden also signaled to russia then a
minor incursion into ukraine
may not really be that big of a deal
remember
russia will be held accountable
if it invades and it depends on what it
does it's one thing if it's a minor
incursion and then we end up having a
fight about what to do and not do etc
vlad noticed that
he also noticed how he left afghanistan
without honor or expertise
sources said putin decided to invade
ukraine after witnessing that mess
putin telegraphed his imperialistic
desires george bush saw it obama saw it
now it's happening under joe biden he
went into georgia crimea and ukraine
but the media blames this latest
invasion you guessed it on trump
and we'll get to that a little later in
the show
russian troops have already invaded the
pro-russian regions of the ukraine so
how much further into the country are
they going to go
and will russia go into poland or the
baltic nato nations
and at what point
are we going to start sending large
numbers of americans to nato countries
well
according to the new york times it's
already started with biden
sending a thousand to five thousand
american troops to eastern european
countries
with the potential to increase that
number tenfold
if things deteriorated officials said
those 5 000 troops from the 82nd
airborne division have already been
deployed to poland
where they're bracing for the worst and
prepping to process thousands of
refugees who i'm sure biden will fly
right here into america
but if biden increases their presence
tenfold that means we may have as many
as 50 000 troops in eastern europe
on high alert
so if putin continues his dream of
patching the old soviet empire back
together
are we prepared to risk our sons to
fight a ground war
in eastern europe
over a nation like estonia
that's a very legitimate question and
it's not an easy one
nothing against the wonderful people of
estonia
i mean that country has the same
population as maine
we have a treaty i know if article 5 is
triggered
happens
are americans behind this in 2022
at a certain point
when do the nations of germany and
france step up and police their own
continent
biden's running out of time
but lucky for us
he has one option left
he can call in the one man out there
with long time experience in the region
someone who knows the ukraine inside and
out
someone who knows european energy policy
and has done big business with moscow
ladies and gentlemen
i think it's time to deploy america's
top diplomat
on our bud
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else